joining us now on the phone from Las
Vegas is Sirius XM host her name is
stormy Warren Sirius XM hosted the
concert stormy good morning you were
there what did you see what happened
well it was what you would expect in the
worst scenario you could possibly
believe watching Jason Aldean perform a
great show and then hearing a Ratatat
Ratatat and thinking it's pyrotechnics
and it's not when did you realise stormy
than it was gunfire after the second
round of Ratatat tests when he knew it
wasn't an audio glitch and I'm standing
right on the side of the stage right
next to the band and when you knew it
was an audio glitch and it wasn't arrow
technics and you knew it was a problem
and and he recognized the sound of
gunfire and when it wouldn't stop it was
a problem what'd you do well first of
all we made sure that we were safe and
Jason and his crew I mean professional
cleared Jason off the band off everybody
was offstage and then I stood there and
a bunch of us stood there going yeah we
should probably leave too and we dove
under the stage and if he was sat behind
the concrete barrier because we knew the
shots were coming from the Mandalay and
you could hear it coming from there it
was loud
high-powered rifle fire coming from the
Mandalay Bay some of the routes
I thought stormy were your listeners
hearing this in real time and what if
anything were you able to relay to them
no we were not broadcasting the Jason
Aldean show at the time and we were not
able to relay any of this so what we
experienced was the same thing every one
of the 30,000 people were experiencing
out there and the festival grounds at
route 91 great festival three days I
mean
no problems everything was just perfect
and then to have the last act of the
last day of the festival marred by this
horrible act we're still trying to put
lead said to hide behind barriers to
hide behind trucks to hide behind
anything we could try to find safe you
can't put that into words this is just
Las Vegas this trip this is fun it's not
supposed to be a place where you're in
danger
I know stormy can you tell us about this
festival we see that there are a lot of
children there what is this event well
you know what I did not see a lot of
children there there are a lot of young
adults there and there are a lot of
young adults and there were adults and
it was a fun
country music event and I'm sure their
children there but my god thank God I
didn't see any of them when I walked
through after the shootings stormy this
event has been going on for a few years
look at the events been going on for a
few years yet for four years stormy what
did you see
when you walked through after the
shooting after after the shooting stops
because we were all hiding and as soon
as we started walking through the
grounds trying to help whoever we said
in the grass in the place where the
audience was standing we could actually
see bodies and it wasn't just one or two
very numerous and and I know the reports
were coming out it's really small
numbers but I can't express to you how
difficult it was to stick over and to
check on and to look at bodies and then
to find ones / still alive and try to
help them and then try to find first
responders who were in anybody I mean I
want to get this across this humanity
this event was amazing everybody chipped
in to help this wasn't
like an event where people were running
away and trying to hide this was a an
event where we knew what was going on
this is a shooting event and there were
people that were hurt and people who are
dead and we were trying to save the ones
who were still alive and everybody
chipped in to help
it was an amazing humanity event but
scary at the same time because we didn't
know what was next
no it sounds very very terrifying storm
and I'm wondering how you're feeling
right now because listen the more we
hear the worse it gets and now you know
you have survived the worst mass
shooting in US history how do you
process that you know you know I mean we
have a group of people like I ran off
with Chris Young country singer and
songwriters and a bunch of our friends
and we gathered the group and he said
let's travel as a pack let's try to get
somewhere safe
that's not backstage at this event where
a shooter has obviously put his bull's
eye
so we ran off and we found a safe place
and we've been sitting here trying to
process this as on our way you're
stepping past bodies and bodies we knew
were gone and the ones that do to help
other witnesses that we've talked to
this morning said that they had no idea
where the bullets were coming from that
they thought that it was multiple
shooters in multiple locations listening
to you you seem to you're saying that
you actually saw something from the
Mandalay Bay Hotel what exactly do you
see well you heard something what
exactly there's a rat-a-tat-tat zone
from the Mandalay Bay and there was no
doubt where it was coming from I didn't
know who's from the roof or wherever but
it was coming from that piece of
property and and as we sat there on the
stage and instead they're watching Jason
Aldean and just to hear that sound
and just don't there's nothing we could
do and and it was absolutely helped
because no German anything he wanted to
wait we did hear from an eyewitness
earlier who said that her husband
actually saw the shots for the lightning
flashes from the gun up in the the
Mandalay Bay so I'm gonna say a little
I'm going to contradict that just a
little bit because there is a strobe
light a half way down on the 14th floor
that was lit up for about three days at
the festival and as we walked across the
street every night I looked up and I saw
this one random strobe light up in this
14th floor window I'm like who would
just put a strobe light in a window and
I think a lot of people are signaling
that it's what they saw I don't think
that was good okay well it doesn't for
our purposes the important thing is that
police found the shooter however they do
locate him they they saw something from
the 32nd floor of the hotel but not for
them what's important is that he is down
and not hurting anyone else stormy
warned thank you thank you for your time
and we're glad to hear you're safe yeah
thank you